when the movie starts we find Mason
having settled down into Suburbia he's
got a wife kids and a pretty
straightforward lawyer job that he's
apparently pretty bored doing just when
he thinks his life is destined to be a
cookie cutter Bland version of what it
used to be he gets a call from a friend
offering him some cash to help out with
a bodyguard type gig it's a one-off
thing and he's going to get a nice
little payday he'll accompany a
journalist to a South American country
where she'll interview their president
and while supposedly a dangerous country
hence the need for a journalist to have
a bodyguard it seems like it'll be an
easy mission for Mason of course if
you're familiar with you know movies you
won't be surprised to find out that
things don't go as planned a major
military coup happens as they're
traveling with the president Mason the
journalist and the president form an
unlikely Trio as they try to stay alive
and perhaps get the country back in
order